first it was take two in zynga then it
was microsoft and activision blizzard
but today sony has announced that it
just bought bungie let's talk about that
and some other playstation news
sony is buying bungie in a deal valued
at 3.6 billion dollars it was announced
today which will make bungie become an
independent subsidiary of sony
interactive entertainment playstation
boss herman hulse said on twitter i'm
absolutely thrilled to welcome bunji to
the playstation family bungie creates
community-driven games with outstanding
technology that are enormous fun to play
and i know that everyone at playstation
studios will be excited about what we
can learn and share together and if that
has you wondering what the state of
destiny and other bungie titles will be
in terms of future releases bungie will
continue to release multi-platform games
going forward and the company will have
the option to self-publish and reach
players wherever they choose to play sie
president and ceo jim ryan also said
we've had a strong partnership with
bungie since the inception of the
destiny franchise and i couldn't be more
thrilled to officially welcome the
studio to the playstation family ryan
went on to say that buying bungie gives
sony access to a much wider audience
with bungie boss pete parsons adding
both bungie and sie believe that game
worlds are only the beginning of what
our ips will become and later saying our
original universes have immense
potential and with sie support we will
propel bungie into becoming a global
multimedia entertainment company
dedicated to delivering on our creative
vision this sounds like it could open
the doors for all types of media and
entertainment for bungie along with its
plans to launch a new ip before 2025
which was already confirmed last year
could this also be the beginning of a
potential destiny 3
this also has me wondering what new
games or new acquisitions we could
possibly hear about next but in the
meantime let me know your thoughts on
sony and bungie joining forces in the
comments below
but another sony news february's
additions to the playstation now catalog
have been announced there are four games
headed to the streaming service this
week headlined by grand theft auto vice
city the definitive edition rockstar's
latest re-release launches on
playstation now starting tuesday
february 1st with the first playstation
store refresh of the month also arriving
that day is little big workshop a game
that puts you in charge of a factory as
you organize the floor manage workers
and design production pipelines through
the darkest times a historical strategy
game about a resistance group in 1933
berlin comes to ps now on february 1st
as well alongside the puzzle game death
squared gta vice city the definitive
edition will be available on ps now
until may 2nd while the other 3 games do
not have end dates this is not out of
the ordinary as some games in the ps now
library are only available for a limited
time
today also marks the 25th anniversary of
final fantasy vii square enix's landmark
rpg that launched on the original
playstation console in 1997 in japan at
an anniversary event held today final
fantasy 7's director and producer
yoshinouro kitusei said that he was
hoping to reveal details on the sequel
to final fantasy vii remake during the
classic rpg's celebratory year last year
remake part 1 co-director motomu
toriyama said that he is sure parts of
future sequels will differ significantly
from the original and that he hopes the
game's honey be in scene will serve as a
good example on how to update and change
parts of the original game for modern
audiences while remake's first sequel is
likely still a long way from being
released there's still plenty of final
fantasy vii content on the horizon final
fantasy vii ever crisis reimagines the
game as an episodic series for mobile
devices that covers the original game
and its spin-offs while a battle royale
title called final fantasy vii the first
soldier has also recently launched
i know it's only monday but we're
already off to a wild start and if you
want to stay up to date on all of the
news and all the latest updates around
sony's acquisition then make sure you
stop by gamespot.com alright leave a
like subscribe and we'll see you
tomorrow for your next gamespot news
update
[Music]
you